James is in Arizona welcome to the Dave
Ramsey show James Merry Christmas by
Christmas mr. Andy how are you better
than I deserve
how can I help going through a
life-changing event right now I just
wanted to get your opinion on a couple
of things one so I'm gonna be going
through a divorce facing here and I was
just wondering if I should sell my house
keep it and just buy buy my wife out yes
I'm sorry how long were you married five
years what happened just a lot of
disagreement so I have a child from a
past relationship that is not
biologically mine but I raised her since
she was six years old and came to the
point where my wife just didn't want to
accept her anymore and you know she's 13
years old now but my ex her mother of
the other daughter she had a lot to do
with it just caused a lot of problems
between me and my wife um yes and I
we're at this point now and we're
separated now I moved out of the house
she's still living there what is the
house worth the house is worth about -
between 260 and 270 and what do you guys
are on it about 183 and what do you make
a year
100k okay any other debts that the two
of you have to deal with that we do know
I do have a couple of debts like I have
about seven grand of past child support
which I've been trying to settle with my
ex on that as well so we should be
coming at some agreement here pretty
soon
I all about there's another child
somewhere yes okay so so basically with
with that the other child that's not
biologically mine I do have a child that
is biologically mine with that I guess
okay just like after making sure I
understood okay all right cool yeah and
so art do you have custody of any of
these children uh joint custody joint
I'm just one just one that's
biologically mine okay
well I'm sorry you're going through this
the I've got it a friend that does
divorce counseling and she says that a
divorce once the decision is made and it
sounds very clear that this decision is
made then in terms of a marriage into a
business transaction and so there's two
pieces of business here that you need to
consider one is you would never leave
someone in the home that you're on the
mortgage unless it's you okay so that
would mean the house was either sold if
she's staying in it wanted to if she
can't reef
it's either refinanced into her name or
or it's sold or its refinanced into your
name
the second thing I would look at is I
would just ask myself if all this
weren't going on on and I make $100,000
a year with a few other miscellaneous
debts here as a single guy would I buy
that house and the answer is probably
not okay you probably just wouldn't be
let's just say you're living in an
apartment you're a single guy which is
what you're getting ready to be right
then you're making 100 grand you got a
little debt you're cleaning up would you
go buy this house I like the house I
like the house but I think down the road
I would end up selling it and you know
mainly mainly the whole question is I
just I feel guilty I feel bad for my
other two children that I currently have
with my life I feel like I'm kind of
kicking them up I found the house you
know okay so you have two children with
the lady you're divorcing no no I have
two children with my wife currently the
one that you're divorced yes yes oh so
is this for I have three total that are
mine and one thirteen year old yeah okay
all right making sure I'm keeping count
okay yeah all right so uh well I I
didn't know they were there until just
now yeah but if she's going to stay in
the house she needs to refinance it she
can't afford it she can't afford and she
shouldn't stay she shouldn't stay in the
house okay and and I don't know why you
would move in the house if she's not
gonna be there unless you're gonna have
them 50% of the time are you no okay
no I mean it'd be more like 40 Senate's
and that's part of my other question I
mean then I'm basically at the point
right now and my job as well that I was
already kind of planning an exit
strategy to start my own business so I
don't know if I should just continue
along with that or not I think the nice
thing for her and used to sell the house
and split the equity and she takes it
and goes and gets her a nice place to
rent in the similar neighborhood where
the schools and so forth they're similar
and she stays you know in the general
area and and that's that's what would
you recommend as far as being the job in
the salary that I have I mean do you
think it would be a good time to start
my own business I don't think it's a
good time emotionally you got four kids
in your life that are all going through
trauma with this situation you're going
through emotional trauma with this
situation and please don't tell me it's
okay because it's not it hurts and I
would get emotionally the other side of
this and get everything settled down let
the dust settle get some of this behind
you and then I would talk about maybe
starting a business but I wouldn't do it
this year no I mean I wouldn't with the
next 12 months for sure hey thanks for
calling I'm sorry you're going through
this